foreign
Cincinnati what's up Adam
uh yeah
my question is I was recently fired from
a job kind of went into panic mode
um decided that
I'm going to pull from my 401k
and pay off my credit card debt and then
use the monthly
you know payments that I'm making to
those credit card debts to roll over
into a car loan and then use the
remainder of the 401K to pay down the
car to try to get out from underneath
that
um what made you feel like that was your
only option
um we
we have a fairly large house mortgage
um I make majority of the money in this
for the income for the house
um we've had enough to maybe make it a
month and a half and I didn't know when
I was going to go back to work
are you working now or
um I have a job that should start Monday
so everything should return to normal as
far as you know the inflow of money
good what's what will be your income at
that point household
um our household income's right about
135 to 140.
all right how much debt do you now have
total
um so I've got a
I'd say we probably got eight in credit
cards and all right 20 in a car
and what about the 401K loan
or did you just withdraw money
I
that 401k was I was very little into it
I only had I completely emptied that one
how much was in there
there was 20 I think 26 in there and I
ended up with like 14 is what it was
after taxes and penalties
so what'd you do with that money have
you already blown through that
no it's that I haven't actually got it
yet but my my plan is is once I get it
is this reverse if you stop and call and
cancel it
I don't think so I think I would do
everything I can say I screwed up I got
fired I freaked out I need to cancel
this I do not want this please take it
please do not send this money
do whatever you can
okay this is a a a fear response
a bear showed up at your cave an actual
real bear scares you to death and you
ran as fast as you could and like a like
a Wiley Coyote cartoon you just bammed
your head into a rock in the cave
okay this wasn't my this wasn't my only
retirement no I I know I know I know I'm
not saying it's your only thing we're
not all that I'm just saying
you don't need it my brother you took a
50 hit on this money and you don't need
the money you didn't need it you have a
great income you start another job on
Monday things got really scary you
panicked it happens to all of us now you
know in the future hey I need emergency
fund but with your salary you can pay
off this debt in short order man is it
28 total now in debt between the credit
cards and the car loan or is there other
debt
uh well I have a home Home Mortgage too
okay so we're going to ignore the
mortgage for now we're going to focus on
this Consumer Debt let's pay off this
credit card first and how quickly could
you pay that off making 140 how quickly
could you pay off eight grand going
scorched Earth throwing everything you
can at it
um
probably six months six months okay
we're gonna hook you up with every
dollar to get a plan for this money
you're making 140. are you taking home
eight nine ten Grand a month
uh yeah between me and my wife yeah
probably okay so if we started looking
at our expenses going outside of just
covering our bills putting food on the
table we're not eating out we're not
going on vacation we're not investing
you could pay this these credit cards
off within two months you got to get
serious though dude and you're like you
got to get real real serious man
we can't want this more than you do
hang on the line we're gonna send you
every dollar premium start making a plan
for your money you've got the income you
don't have to do stupid anymore you're
working hard for it now let's do
something good with it which is pay off
this debt get an emergency fund in place
and start Building Wealth the right way